Congratulation for completing Unit 1 of our introduction to theoretical computer science.
We have introduced a lot of essential concepts and tools and you have managed
to master them and now have them at your disposal.
You know what a RAM. You know about O notation or big O notation.
You know how to analyze algorithms and you've also learned to understand
three very, very important problems in computer science known as clique,
independent set and vertex cover.
And while discussing these problems, you've also learned about the important concepts of
polynomial time algorithms, exponential time algorithms, and the connected concepts
of tractable problems and intractable problems.
Having all of these concepts and tools at your disposal, you're ready to dive deeper
into figuring out if we can make Alice, Bob and Carol happy by finding out that their problems
are tractable or if we have to bring them bad news and show that their problems are intractable,
but for now again congratulations.